we've talked a lot about cells in
general but what i thought i would do in
this video is focus on plant cells and
in particular focus on the cell walls of
plant cells so this right over here this
is a drawing of a plant cell and the
thing that might jump out at you
immediately is instead of drawing it as
just kind of a
roundish shape like that the way i've
drawn a lot of other cells i've drawn
this as kind of a cubic structure a
rectangular prism and that's because
plant cells can have a structure like
that and so the next question is well
what gives them that shape what allows
them to to form that kind of cubic
rectangular prism shape and the answer
is it's the cell wall
so that's the cell
cell wall so let's make sure we can
orient ourselves properly in this
picture so clearly if i was if i didn't
have this cut out all i would be seeing
is the outside all i would be seeing is
the cell wall but we've cut it out and
we can see the different layers we have
the cell wall on the outside right below
that
right below that we have the cellular
membrane or the plasma membrane so
that's the cell
cellular cellular membrane
cellular
membrane
right under that and then under that the
cellular membrane this control is is
containing the cytoplasm and inside of
the cytoplasm we have all sorts of
things this big thing that is taking up
a lot of the volume inside of this plant
cell that's a vacuole which we have
described in other
in other
in other videos vacuole it's a
combination of this internal pressure
things like the vacuole and just frankly
the pressure from from all of the fluid
inside the cell pushing outwards plus
the cell wall kind of holding it all in
that's what gives plants their structure
that's why a plant is able to grow and
be a plant is able to grow and be
upright so that's my drawing of a of a
plant i actually have a plant in my room
that i'm looking at right now and it's
able to grow and be upright
and so you have the cell wall you have
the cellular membrane you have the other
organelles i have some chloroplasts here
key for photosynthesis have my our good
friends mitochondria we have our nuclear
membrane i should say this yellow thing
is the inner nuclear membrane has the
dna inside then you have the endoplasmic
reticulum kind of containing that the
rough er containing the ribose or having
the ribosomes on the membrane the smooth
er not having the ribosomes golgi
apparatus so that's a little bit of
review but our focus here is on the cell
wall so let's go back to that so if we
zoom in on this if we zoom in on the
cell wall right over here we can look at
we can look at this diagram and over
here
it might be a little bit surprising to
you because when i've always imagined a
a wall a cell wall i imagine something
like a brick wall something that's
impenetrable but this drawing shows us
something different and just to be clear
what's going on here
so this is our cellular membrane it's
already wrote cellular membrane so right
over here i have my lipid bilayer and
then right on top of that i have the
cell wall but you see it isn't just a
thick like a brick wall something that's
impenetrable you see you have all of
these polysaccharide fibers running
across it so you have things like
cellulose which we saw as a polymer of
glucose arranged in a certain way hemi
cellulose which has different types of
monomers associated with it we have
pectin which is another polysaccharide
and all of these things you've actually
probably eaten if not today probably in
the last week when we talk about fiber
in your diet you're talking about things
like the cellulose and the pectin things
that your body can't digest when you eat
a plant you're getting it because you're
eating their cell walls
and it does cool things like slows the
absorption of glucose in your intestines
it absorbs water so i guess you could
say things pass a little bit
easier but just to see but the the key
thing here is this isn't a wall this
actually allows or it is a wall it's
officially the cell wall but it's not a
thick it's not an impenetrable wall like
you might associate the wall of the room
that you're in you can see that it has
space for small molecules to flow and
it's really more like a mesh or like a
fabric and so the cellular membrane
actually has access to this this to the
fluid and to the molecules that are
between the cells and so just to be
clear what we're looking at this layer
right here that's a cellular membrane
that's the lipid bilayer
this right over here this is the cell
wall do that in a different color
that is the
that is the cell wall and then right
above the cell wall that's the space
between the cells which we call the
middle lamella
so the space between the cells we call
the middle lamella
so this also is this right over here is
also the middle lamella
so all of that is interesting but you
might say okay well how hard is the cell
i get that it's a mesh but you know
clearly the cells are able
or the plants are able to stand upright
is that because the cell wall provides
all of that rigidity and the answer is
kind of the cell wall is like this mesh
it helps these cells have their shape
but if you stop watering a plant you're
going to see it you're going to see it
kind of
wilt over and that's because part of
that that its ability to stand up is
from the internal pressure of the cells
but also part of its shape is the actual
cell wall now some of you might say well
i've seen plants that are much much more
rigid than this plant you've just drawn
what about things like trees what about
wood wood seems very rigid in fact so
rigid that we can build actual walls out
of wood and the answer there is
these more mature plants actually once
the the cell has stopped growing and you
have your cell wall more layers of
cellulose and other molecules can be
built to form what's called a secondary
cell wall so this could be viewed as a
primary cell wall and then a thicker
secondary cell wall could be built which
gives a much much much more rigidity and
so when you look at wood what gives
wooden structure even if you were to
take out all of the water even if you
were to dehydrate the wood it's still
going to have its rigidity because the
cellulose layers and the other molecules
are so thick that it's able to have its
rigid form
now the last thing i want to talk about
we've already seen that the cellular
membrane has access to
the the molecules floating around
between between cells but there's
actually also direct tunnels between
adjacent plant cells and those direct
tunnels i've drawn here on this outside
of the cell walls these little yellow
circles these are plasmodesmata plasmo
these are plasmodesmata and to get a
better understanding of what they're
like imagine this is one cell so i'll
write mirror cell
one and let's say this is cell two
cell two right over here and have a
cross section you see the plasmo
you see the plasmodesmata are these
tunnels that form between not just the
membrane and the cell wall and the
plasma
it forms between the two cells and so
you can actually have a flow of cytosol
and small molecules directly
directly between these two cells and if
you want to get a little bit more
involved in the structure you have this
kind of smooth endoplasmic reticulum
pipe going through it but i want to make
it very clear
because a lot of times when you study
biology it's all explained it seems all
neat and clean a textbook but people are
still studying exactly
why do we have these things why are they
why why are they necessary what gets
transported across these things and how
are they able to transport it under what
conditions are they so all of these
areas when you were to kind of dig one
layer deeper than frankly i'm talking
about you're getting into an area of
active research so anyway hopefully this
whole thing gives you a little bit more
appreciation for the wood around you the
plants the house plants around you
and even the salad that you might have
for lunch